une nouvelle journée sombre sur le dakar
le motard italien fabrizio meoni deux
fois vainqueur du rallye est mort d'une
crise cardiaque pendant l'étape en
mauritanie après une chute
il avait 47 ans et deux enfants c'est le
deuxième décès en deux jours le choc est
rude pour les coureurs et les
organisateurs julien vous le dakar
endeuillées
c'est patrick zaniroli lui-même qui a
annoncé la triste nouvelle à l'arrivée
de la spéciale
choquée sonnés les motards du dakar
viennent de perdre un ami
vous savez j'ai un fils comme c'est
difficile de penser qu'il ya de nuit il
m'a dit qu'il voulait arrêter le dakar
pour voir son fils faire du motocross
tout comme je veux le faire km 185 un
secteur a priori sans difficulté le
groupe de tête n'allait pas vite
il y avait des poussières camp mais
honni est tombé à terre donc de suite
que c'était grave je souhaitais sur sa
moto pour essayer de trouver ce un
palier des 1 j'ai du mal à trouver la
déclencher et puis élite appelé les
secours et puis j'ai entendu les parties
à 47 ans fabrizio meoni double vainqueur
de l'épreuve participer à son treizième
dakar il laisse une femme et deux
enfants